and the previous episode of Walking Dead
what if my parents come home and I'm not
there I've got my walkie-talkie in case
they try that way hey there were some
batteries in one of those boxes here you
could have some tie yeah she died
ah now you're back why did you buy delay
no I'll come a time to go on wherever
she is I have to find her dead no you
know how they died
you said goodbye I've never got to see
my finger well nothing like this
oh [ __ ] benders not got a mask man you
bet Oh blah son of a [ __ ]
oh god don't let them get to me go back
Shinichi Lee Jimmy this is not a
discussion it's just something I got to
crack him you know let's [ __ ] get
back into this I can't be all
do you want to talk
it's as they focus the city we need to
stay focused on what we're doing I know
we can't just take a minute but you're
not a machine
look clean this is a shitty time but I
want to clear something up what is now
with Kenny gone means Omid and I have to
stay safe for her yeah
you did yeah you do let me take all the
risk that's not what I mean necessarily
it's what I me toward we got a do huh
okay hey I don't even know anymore I
know when you go on such a long journey
and you really care about the characters
and then when they die in such a way I
don't know like I said bad and then he
just dies anyway and I don't I don't
it's hard to explain I usually don't
really care that much when sad things
happen like to the moon run a small step
ahead that's supposed to be like a super
sad story but it didn't ever do that
much to me because it just felt a little
too cheesy for me I get felt too much
buildings are full I don't know where
the next meal is but you know I don't
that's the thing to say I I didn't mean
it's fine that's girl don't be angry Lee
no one likes an angry guy all right
I would I would drop something on their
head or something if I with them
oh [ __ ] are we gonna cross that show
Soto is around the corner of the block
well at least it doesn't look like a
deathtrap
god damn well it looked like a deathtrap
to me Oh first you're the lightest he's
gonna busted leg you're walking for to
do it's a decision doesn't make itself
I go fighters first case anything
happens out there you sure yeah
come on Kelly you can do it do it for
clammy man you're almost there man
just go nice and slow
I can't control how fast I go Mahmoud I
could probably pull this off I mean if
you think about it this is a really
heavy sign and they can't just leave
have it signs just being a potato and
the tradition for some people good
special event there's a sponsored thing
I don't know I don't see now it can fall
out because oh [ __ ] God physically that
should not have fallen out - you should
have fallen out and are you okay fired
I'm kind of [ __ ] here what are you
gonna do
I'm going fine I'm going for it going
for it what does that mean it means I'm
already bitten I just have to push my
way through what the [ __ ] what da
finally when you get down what the [ __ ]
does that mean it means what it sounds
like hotels around the corner
fine Clementine and me as soon as you
can you're crazy
snow the way but here's my number is it
going down get a good nap
what are you doing the plan was to go
across anyway what the [ __ ] what Anna
Lee you are one badass [ __ ] I
didn't know that with a glass shard
but as [ __ ] name yeah [ __ ] you
that's right [ __ ] you and [ __ ] you and
you know what I got a speaking for you
[ __ ] you I have I do I be out of this
story it's called [ __ ] you that's right
it's a great story how about this one
Hey yeah I'll be out of my truck yo
that's God [ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself what's up what's up hey
Ron
anyone else want to [ __ ] I have you
heard about the story don't [ __ ]
yourself that's right what's my middle
name go [ __ ] yourself
[ __ ] guys lay [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh that's a car
it's in that the car we took the medical
supplies from Edith maybe they just use
the same model ballast epic bells [ __ ]
it uh this game is just it gets better
and better and you really don't expect
it to get better and better
honestly I in episode three I didn't
expect it to be good at all I was
thinking not they're probably out of
ideas by now to make it interesting but
nope
they have sleeves up there they have a
whole card of deck up their sleeves all
right what the [ __ ] is that
no jump-scares man I'm I'm gonna little
fishy with the jump scares
that
what's going on in here
that looks like a trap
what's going on here
what is this for
oh [ __ ] there is I got us adjoining
rooms uh-huh hello whoa
okay this is civil you look horrible
well you look like a [ __ ] douche I'm
look badass go over there do I look like
someone who follows instructions I guess
so
put that things down let me out
who's out there it's me Lee oh the [ __ ]
quiet please sweetie your things there
I only had this radio this is all of God
crazy if it believes that he's a [ __ ]
idiot look his buddy
look you travel light I don't believe
you
Yankee farm that's what I thought
I didn't give the glass shard sit down
let's see what this [ __ ] has to
say do you know who I am
some friend no I don't know anything
about you you wouldn't people like you
don't
now you're thinking who would have it
out for me huh a few weeks back there
might have been a station wagon in the
forest full of all sorts of food yeah
that's what I thought it was the car
it was the cars you need to survive
well me and Clementine didn't touch it
I'm not some cannibal Lee some killer
out in the woods some villain I'm just
uh oh he lost his daughter coach Little
League or I did take from you your
people didn't I didn't agree with it
that's what Clementine said why didn't
you
she didn't wonder them want me to she
didn't want you to do a lot of things
what do you want me to say I don't want
you to say anything I want you to know
what happened well I can already guess
but have you ever hurt somebody you care
about
maybe now we get to have no one happen
of course why you kill the mayor my wife
my wife
Clementine said she wasn't with you
she's then revoked I'm a girl
how
and a lot of my worries
she traveled for work I didn't like that
I wanted a family a reasonable thing
don't want so we fought and it made my
biggest fear come true yet sick one day
on my way to class cancel didn't win
hole found her there was someone else
killed him you should not kill a man I
was mad at him for so long I can't
imagine how much pain she felt how about
you
I hurt her so bad who you thought her
and Adam went miss huh I took him out
hunting even though my wife said he was
too young I figured he had to learn I
came back without him and the look on
her face said you are a monster why we
all went out looking for him we never
found him I hurt her so bad and then we
came back and all our stuff was gone
your people be
that [ __ ] in the ball cap his stupid
[ __ ] wife
I could have earned her trust back if
they hadn't made our situation so
desperate so we [ __ ] them over huh
I'm sorry I'm sorry the hungrier we got
the more she blamed me until she finally
took our daughter Elizabeth and left
maybe that's the girl we saw in the
woods they didn't get far I found him a
day later in the road do I look like a
monster to you
kind of we don't all do some more than
others
I'm not like you
you walked a little girl into a dairy
full of sick people and let them get
their hands on her come on are you
really upset about that I was trying to
find someplace safe for her you
abandoned a defenseless grieving woman
you weren't back there you brought her
to the most dangerous place in this city
where she could have died I can't leave
her alone at the house alone she would
have been better off know what she went
in what's your [ __ ] problem I don't
understand his kid all this yeah their
walkie-talkie probably yeah
you're a monster you're a murderer and a
thief and I'm gonna hurt you so bad are
you [ __ ] kidding me
I didn't steal from you I didn't steal
from you but think of everything else
you did was so [ __ ] one it's a
[ __ ] zombie apocalypse you did come
on her she was in get over yourself
get over yourself man will you listen to
me I need you to hear this before what
happens next I can take care of her we
can have a family out of the knife I
think I don't even know how old she is
she's eight wrong she's nine no better
than Earth Day was six days ago I know
how to be a dad you know she wouldn't be
exposed to what she has been with you
I got bidding okay I was bitten you or
what yeah I probably don't have a whole
lot of time
Wow okay then
no you're not taking her Li I said No
hey honey I think this is all gonna work
out are you I'm glad to
I wish it wouldn't have had to get this
bad but it's all over on what's going on
what is he new instrument I'm super
confused seeing you like this
I just miss your smile honey the bottle
I miss you so much Tess you're gonna
like Clementine a lot though she's not
my patroling Clementine she wouldn't
hurt a fly
I don't get the battle don't hurt a man
don't hurt him
I can't I can't I can't
Wow are you [ __ ] serious no no no no
don't hurt him don't kill it man don't
[ __ ] kill him I mean just go worry
you don't take Claire from me
okay maybe not all right brothers hope
you enjoyed this episode don't miss
tomorrow because that's the last episode
it's gonna be a heartbreaking one like a
pretty fugitoid subscribe to come abroad
today and I'll see you next episode of a
mommy I'm your breast
you